The funniest is all the people were
telling you have to hate Muslims. Oh,
hate the Muslims.
>> A week after
uh 9/11
and the email reads, where is the real
pilot?
Whoa.
If the hijackers really were Muslims,
why would they steal the identities of
fellow Muslims and implicate them?
Wouldn't they be more likely to steal
Israeli identities and put the blame on
Israelis?
>> This is the new Sajaria in town. On the
day of judgment, the first thing we will
be asked about
>> is our prayer. Now, imagine being part
of a project that teaches thousands of
people around the world. For just 100,
>> you can help teach 20 to 60 people like
me learn how to pray salah. And when
they teach their children
>> and their children's children,
>> the reward continues.
>> Do not miss the
>> donate today
>> and earn rewards that last beyond your
lifetime.
>> Go to the link and donate now.
Asalamaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends. I
came across this video from Taka Carlson
and Jenk H. And subhan Allah um you
would think that people are just going
to stop like Tak Carson etc. you know
talk about the Gaza war etc. But no,
because now they are questioning things
and they want answers. And this is what
happens where Allah subhana wa ta'ala
exposes the truth because Allah has a
plan. Sometimes we get frustrated with
Allah's plan. But Allah has a plan. We
see the pixel and it doesn't make sense.
Yeah. But when you look outside, you're
like, "Wow, that's what Allahh has and
we don't see." And you can see
unraveling as we speak. Now, here's a
video that I saw Carlson and he made
some very profound points against Ben
Shapiro, the devil. These these people
are satanic, okay? Zionists. They are
satanic and they are working for a new
world order. Now, this is the video. Uh,
and then we're going to come to 9/11,
the new audio recordings, well, the old
audio recordings that show that the
accent of the hijackers are more Hebrew
than it is Arabic. So, we're going to
come to that as well, in let's just
quickly um, watch this one.
>> The funniest is all the people who are
telling you have to hate Muslims. Oh,
hate the Muslims. Ben Shapiro or Mark
Levin hate Muslims. Why aren't those
same people calling for full disclosure
of the 9/11 documents? It's kind of
weird, isn't it? If you really wanted to
prove that MUSLIMS ARE BAD, YOU WOULD
WANT all the 911 documents disclosed,
wouldn't you? Just so you could sort of
play out the horrifying details that led
to those fabled 19 Arabs with box
cutters committing the biggest act of
terror in American history. Why would
you ever want to keep any of that
secret? Has Mark Lean ever called for
the full disclosure of the 9/11 docs?
Well, why wouldn't you? That would kind
of make your case the Muslims are bad,
wouldn't it? Just put a nail in the
coffin of all the jihadis in America.
Invest Piro on that. Shut up, conspiracy
theorist. Just keep in mind when people
tell you trust the government, maybe
there's another agenda there.
>> I mean that's a very very valid point
there. If you can if you look at it
brothers and sisters, subhan Allah, you
can see that he's making a point is if
you believe Ben Shapiro and this that
and if Muslims were behind this, if
Arabs and Muslims were behind this,
surely you would want the 911 files to
be made absolutely public. So people can
see that the connections that it has to
Islam and Muslims, but there is none.
And this shows you that the fact that
they're trying to cover up and you know
number one Ben Shapiro the biggest
spokesman for Israel and Mosad uh this
scumbag they want disorder in land. They
want the Christians and the Muslims to
fight each other while they make the new
world order the greater Israel plan. And
subhan Allah listen to the new audio
recordings which is being asked. Subhan
Allah. The question that people are
asking is hold on a second. These
individuals in the planes are speaking
Hebrew. And then we're going to go to
Jen where he tells us message from EP um
Epstein uh to uh Gizlain Maxwell asking
a question which is absolutely bizarre.
Okay. And this is unraveling in front of
our eyes and no one's talking about it.
Here is the audio recording of the
accents being Hebrew. The voice of the
hijacker heard from the hijacked plane's
voice recorder reveals that the accent
of the hijacker matches an Israeli
Hebrew accent.
>> Just take quiet and you'll be okay to
the airport.
>> The next transmission comes seconds
later.
>> Everything was okay.
FBI Director Mueller, BBC News, and ABC
have confirmed that seven of the 19
Muslims whose mugsh shots were flashed
around the world, did not die in the 911
crashes.
>> Interesting. So, these nine hijackers,
whoever they are, they were not even
dead. They are alive and ident.
Let's let's carry on. They are alive and
well and are victims of identity theft.
An eighth accused Muslim died one year
before the 911 hijackings even occurred.
Who stole their identities? And why
isn't the FBI looking for them? If the
hijackers really were Muslims, why would
they steal the identities of fellow
Muslims and implicate them? Wouldn't
they be more likely to steal Israeli
identities and put the blame on
Israelis? If the hijackers were
Israelis, wouldn't they be likely to
steal the identities of Muslims and put
the blame on Muslims?
>> There you go. You know, if if the
hijackers are um Muslims, why would you
hijack your identity of fellow Muslims?
Subhan Allah. And now this gets really
really weird because why is this email
which we're going to show in Subhan
Allah. Uh watch for yourself guys. These
Epstein files, why are they trying to
hide it? Okay, now listen to this from
Jenicians and big pharma and defense
contractors. I've explained to you all
the things that are wrong with media in
a hundred different ways, but even I
didn't expect this. Wait, there was a
shadow 9/11 commission and there's not a
single national media reporter that's
interested in that and has done a story
about it. Okay, now let me give you the
second email
also to Gain Maxwell. This time from a
guy named Philip Lavine. And God forbid
anybody should ask who he is. This one's
date is even more important.
September 18th, 2001,
a week after
uh 911.
And the email reads, "Where is the real
pilot?"
Whoa.
What is that?
Where's the real pilot? A week after 911
and that email is going to Gain Maxwell.
If you don't think this is an
interesting story, you're not a
journalist. If you're covering up this
story, you're not a journalist.
Well, literally no one in corporate
media is covering this. So, apparently
there are zero journalists in legacy
media. None. I mean, but it's beyond
that. There's no one who doesn't think
that this is interesting. It doesn't
mean that you can't disprove it. I I
don't know how you would, but what what
you I know what you would do. You would
do investigative reporting and you would
try to figure out, wait, that's super
interesting. What do they mean real
pilot? Could it be the biggest
coincidence in human history that they
don't mean 911 even though it's a week
after 9/11 and they're you're emailing
someone who's very very likely an
Israeli spy, but you it's a different
pilot from a different plane maybe. But
that's when you would have to do
journalism and you would have to
investigate it and you would find this
remarkable and you'd want to look into
what the hell was the shadow commission?
Why is someone asking Delane Maxwell
where the real pilot is? But we've got
literally none of that from our national
media. So, okay, I mean
it forces us to wonder, are you in on
it?
>> 100% 100%. Robert Maxwell, who stole
nuclear intelligence and gave it to the
Russians. Okay. To God knows for
whatever reason. Then her his daughter
Giz Maxwell who's connected to Epstein
uh the islands etc. all connected to
Israel and Mossad. Then you've got the
laughing Zionist the laughing Jews
Zionist when the 911 attacks happening.
Then you've got the Hebrew accents and
the planes. Then you've got nine uh 9 to
people of ident Muslims identity some of
them who have passed away or still
alive. Uh subhan Allah. Then you got Ben
Shapiro and the rest like Todd Carson
saying uh subhan Allah that he's saying
do not release the files or whatever for
that matter. And you're looking thinking
subhan Allah and you're trying to tell
us Muslims and no media coverage. And
then you've got Giz Maxel Maxwell's
email to Epstein uh asking who are the
real pilots? Where are the real pilots?
Where are the real pilots? Just imagine
if a Muslim country was organized
business and there's someone called
Katijah who works with someone called
Abdul who had a pedophile ring whatever
and she was working with the Islamic
secret intelligence service etc. There
will be global up uproar guys. There
will be global uproar. And subhan Allah,
Allah subhana wa ta'ala tells us and
this is why it makes Islam more true
because Allah talks about these fitna
makers. Okay, these Zionist scumbags.
Allah talks about them. There are good
and bad Jews. We are talking about the
evil vile Jews here. Okay, why is nobody
going and asking the Jewish community to
condemn Epstein? This is something that
you can even come and say there's some
Talmudic things that goes back to the
religion. You can you can do that. But
no, nothing is being said. It's just all
being silent. Okay. Now, Americans,
you're journalists. Why are they not
coming out and asking questions? What
the hell is going on? You are controlled
by Mossad. Mossad is trying to make
Muslims and Christians fight each other.
We can intellectually have
disagreements. That's all good. Fight
each other while they are building their
greater Israel plan. They are waiting
for their Messiah. And the Christians
are aiding them because they're thinking
when the Messiah comes, he's going to
make all of those Jews either kill them
or make them Christians. Okay? And the
Jews are waiting for their Messiah
because all of us are going to be slaves
under them because that's how they see
the go as to be okay. So much so. And
they hate you Christians with all Jewish
respect. They spit at you. They don't
believe in your God. We as Muslims
don't. In our book, Jesus is blessed. In
the Bible, he's cursed. Okay? And he is
cursed by the the the Jews as well.
Subhan Allah. So the question is, what
the hell is going on? And are you guys
not waking up as Muslims? We need to be
clued up and know this stuff. And there
they come to us again about EP
pedophilia. You guys are the main
culprits from Jim Jimmy Savos to your
higher echelons to Epstein. Yes. And not
only that, Epstein praising Tommy
Robinson. Can you imagine me being
praised by a pedophile? A full-blown the
biggest pedophile in human history.
Maybe the biggest pedophile using it to
blackmail the high the people at the top
for the gain of Israel. They are like uh
Kandis Owen said, they are coming for
your children. They are coming for your
children. Yes. And and and um uh not
only that, Subhan Allah. I'll just show
you one other thing as well. Subhan
Allah. Of of a of a clip. Tom Alexander.
So he's the guy who was an Israeli cyber
security official goes to Vegas and
looks to rape a American girl, right? So
he's like, "Oh, there's a great
opportunity for basically pedophile
tourism. I'll go to America." And I know
as an Israeli I won't I won't be held
accountable. So he gets caught in a
sting operation. Got him. Okay, good.
Gets caught with eight other Americans
who were also involved in that
operation. The eight Americans are in
jail right now in Nevada. Alexander back
to Israel. Free ride.
How?
>> But wait, you can't say that the
Americans who did something terrible
should be in prison. Great. Wonderful.
Totally agree. But the Israeli is
allowed to do it and he can rape any
American girl he wants here and he gets
a free ride back to Israel. No. No. So
right now he's technically under arrest,
but our government isn't doing anything
to try to get him back.
>> So there you go. They are raping your
children. They they are doing acts of
pedophilia on your children. On your
kids, Americans. Yes. And we as Muslims
are at the forefront of protecting your
children and saying them don't sexualize
them, don't sexual objectify them. They
are children, this trans this etc. And
we are the ones that are are trying to
corrupt you. We are the ones that saying
don't drink alcohol. Don't do gambling,
sex outside of marriage. Everything that
destroys you while you've got rabbis
owning pornhub. You can't make this up.
You cannot make this up. That's all I'm
going to say. Inshallah. Keep a close
eye on this inshallah. And may Allah
carry on exposing them. We need to give
more light to this and as Muslims be
more informed inshallah. That's all I
have to say in May Allah open the eyes
of these people more and Allahh expose
them because the whole world is seeing
their reality and these people are evil
and satanic. Till next time
we are teaching people how to pray
>> and every time they pray you get the
share in that reward. And when they
teach their children
>> and their children's children
>> the reward continues. Every fud
is every recitation. For just £100, you
can help teach 20 to 60 people like me.
Learn how to pray salah. Donate today.